Speaker 1: Let's go to Ty from Iowa. Ty
from Iowa. Welcome to the program. What
can I do for you today?
Speaker 2: Hello,
David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can. It sounds like
you're probably on speakerphone, but it's good
enough that I won't make a big deal out of it.
Speaker 2: I'm using a blue yeti, Mike.
Speaker 1: Blue Yeti. Oh, wow. Okay.
Interesting. All right, well, please proceed, sir.
Speaker 2: Okay, So I wanted to bring this up just
because I've been kind of thinking about it,
So I know that you have said before that the
right wing in Europe has more in common with
the Democratic Party in America than they do
with the Republican Party.
Speaker 1: I've said that.
Speaker 2: Well, I thought I thought
I heard you say maybe I was wrong.
Speaker 1: I just that I don't think like I
don't what I have said. What I have said is
that mainstream Democrats in the U.S. are
certainly centrists in most of Europe and
even center right in some of Europe.
Speaker 2: I see. Yes. But I was just
going to say, unfortunately, it doesn't
seem like that's the case everywhere. So
if so, I would kind of consider the Democratic
Party to kind of be globally more center right
and the Republican Party more as hyper partizan
or even far right. Okay. And it's obviously not
as nearly as common as in other countries,
but we've seen in Brazil with Bolsonaro is
sometimes called the trump of the tropics. And
their supporters rioted in Brasilia, the Free
Thomas Plaza and we've seen in Hungary with Orban
and. Literally with Melanie, I think is her name,
right? Maloney. Maloney. Yeah. Yeah. So how
do you think things like these kind of started
and how dangerous would you say these types of
movements are for other countries, like we've
already seen Russia turn into a dictatorship?
Speaker 1: You're saying how how does what start.
Speaker 2: Like, how do these how do these these
kind of populist right wing movements kind of
just form and just kind of take people over? Well.
Speaker 1: So here's the thing. As the it's often
starts with. The employment of populist rhetoric
by badly intentioned individuals. And this is why
I've said before, populist rhetoric can be a
dangerous thing because right wing populists
and left wing left wing populists will say very
similar things. But then when they get into power,
they do very different things. And so with a
lot of these situations, it really is a populist
rhetoric by a would be authoritarian that the
people fall for. Sometimes they fall for it in
a context where things are already very bad in
the country, Venezuela, Russia, other places.
And so I think it's it really
starts with the rhetoric,
at least in places that are at least superficially
democratically elected, if that makes sense.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I got. And I
feel like a lot of this stuff
can't be done with populism, unfortunately.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And remember, populism is a
rhetoric. It's not a policy proposal. Tucker
Carlson and Bernie. Agree. The middle class
is really getting screwed in this country. Bernie
thinks it's by, you know, corporations and elected
officials who do nothing for them. Tucker is like
they're getting screwed by like BLM and looters
and brown people from Mexico. Right. So they both
are like the middle class is getting screwed.
Very different ideas as to how we deal with it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I'm just really kind of hoping
that every single time one of these people doesn't
get their way. Yeah, they're going to urged her
supporters to do violence. I really hope that's
not going to be a thing, but it just happened
twice. It's really weird that it's happened twice.
Speaker 1: I hope not as well. I'm with you, Tai.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: All
right. Thank you for your call. Taking my
call. Very much. Appreciate it. Thank you.